welcome to the magical world of oculus a
place where you can leave the doldrums
of reality behind and step into a
virtual landscape of boundless
possibility VR is for everyone here's a
list of amazing titles that will whisk
you away from the struggles of everyday
life but you know just don't forget to
eat every so often
who says you have to leave the house
when you can see the world with the most
immersive Google Earth experience to
date couch-surf through countless iconic
locales from bustling city scapes to
majestic mountain ranges Google Earth
gives you all 360 degrees of what our
planet has to offer it's also a great
giant monster simulator and kind of
makes you feel like a colossus so
there's that
considering a side hustle as an
astronaut but afraid of a terrifying
vacuum of outer space try mission ISS
where you can interact with a fully
realized recreation of the International
Space Station complete with zero gravity
simulation interactive missions and one
hell of a view
there we just saved you eight years for
that astrophysics degree you're welcome
[Music]
when you combine a badass zombie hunter
with a fast and furious blue cat alien
Ally add the frenetic energy of director
Robert Rodriguez and sprinkle in a
healthy mix of explosions skydiving and
bionic arm combat what do you get you
get the limit a cinematic experience
made exclusively for VR drop into your
rift and hold on tight for the most
immersive action-adventure of the year
hi-yah found you teeth may want to pop
those babies back in at some point VR
can be thrilling VR can be chilling but
who says VR can't be relaxing with
nature treks you can settle it to 15
interactive Zen landscapes from pastoral
forests to tropical beaches to wondrous
cosmic vistas with over 60 varieties of
animals to discover and subtle music
cues that sync with your actions this is
VR at its most serene sit back relax and
ship
unleash your inner artist with will an
immersive and intuitive drawing tool
that allows you to not only illustrate
your own personal Technicolor
abominations
but animate them as well all within a
fully three-dimensional space and if
you're not artistically inclined phil
has a number of pre-loaded illustrations
to interact with the only limit is your
imagination
just try to keep it pg people
[Music]
there's so much to see and do and be in
the world of VR and we've barely shown
you the tip of the iceberg whether
you're a die-hard gamer or not oculus
has something special for everyone so
for more info and other great VR titles
along with some cool VR apps stick with
GameSpot
[Music]